almost all of the kids that I know that
grew up listening to metal or hardcore
you can't listen to that and not have a
rebellious streak in you yeah you
definitely can't listen to that and not
have a Reveal Your streak in you and
that did kind of drive my way of
thinking a lot when I was growing up do
you think that can be trained that
creativity yeah I think creativity can
be trained just like any other natural
trait some people are going to have more
propensity to be creative than someone
else and some people are more rigid than
other people in the way they think and
you can take someone that's more rigid
and you can make them more creative but
everyone's going to have some kind of a
limitation where did you fall on that
spectrum that was a very rebellious kid
and I think Rebellion could be somehow
tied to creativity and looking at things
and saying hey that doesn't make sense
to me I had to say it was a pretty
strong degree of both of those things
and that's what made me who I am